who do you have
okay i i want to get get to a few errors
of your career but
um out of the new generation um
who who who's got your attention
um chris alder fax you know what i'm
saying
um a lot of other people too um and you
know
action bronson you know all them type of
cats
freddie gibbs you know what i'm saying
like people like that i'm
not i'm that's that's that's my wave
that's my wave right there have you
tapped in with the core day kid
not yet you know i feel like you guys
would you guys would make some beautiful
music together man
your phone just just dipped out you
there you're back
okay you're back i'm back
my phone died man i figured that's what
happened
yeah i'm on my other phone now oh good
man look p rock
um we were talking about some of the
newer artists that you were [ __ ] with
you were saying you loved griselda
uh freddie gibbs have you you and gibbs
haven't worked together yet
not yet but we talking about it we've
been talking about it you know what i'm
saying
yeah i i might you know if if it happens
that'd be dope you know what i'm saying
um right right now i'm more concentrated
on
um because i see cats as busy so i'm
doing
you know my own stuff with my artist
amir who's gonna be
really near amir okay